it was in this room when I first moved
in here I had a roommate my friend Tina
who was a regular on the Dick Van Dyke
variety show which is where Andy Kaufman
broke in okay so they were sort of
friends so she brought him over here one
night and he and I spent two hours in
this room having an argument an argument
the last two hours you know he was very
much into wrestling mm-hmm
and was trying to convince me as a
psychologist that the world was really
like wrestling with the guys that
basically white hats and black hats a
good guys and bad guys and I was
explaining to him he was frightfully
naive and that it was much more like
roller derby because there were much
more characters involved and for two
hours we've argued about that really
right in this world in this very room
that you're in matter if you could feel
the spirit it jogged my memory because
before you even you discussed taxi in
one of your interviews but even before
that I just thought back to being a kid
and what was my favorite and it was the
two Christopher Lloyd and Andy Kaufman
it was interesting that a good friend of
mine that Jeffrey knows also was also
regular on that show and was at his
audition and said he did his his bits
and then he picked up a copy of The
Great Gatsby familiar with the Great
Gatsby he knows that that was my
undergraduate thesis so he picked up and
helped me the Great Gatsby and he
started to reading it
not like a funny reading like a series
just reading it the way if I said I read
this aloud and everybody's come out
staring at each other and five minutes
goes by and that's a long time to be
sitting there watching a guy who's
supposed to be auditioning reading a
book and they're staring at him like
this guy so Mars this is so I heard 10
minutes goes by and somebody starts to
kind of giggle a little bit and within
12 minutes
everybody's rolling on the floor people
like holding the chest cuz it hurts so
much and laughing so hard and all he did
was kept reading yeah it's really tragic
because he was so young and he was so
talented I actually went to grammar
school with his brother
and I I I think I must have met and II
was a little kid you know but I was when
man the moon came out when the Jim
Carrey movie came out I remember they
used to do this thing called II II
Hollywood true stories I don't know they
still do him and I would happen to be
channel surfing and there was this kid
Mike count Michael Kaufman
who you know sometimes people's faces
really stick there you still see the
child face right it was just weird cuz
it all came back
you know from that's like sixth grade or
seventh grade we were in together Wow
then they moved to Great Neck
there was a Manhattan and they moved out
to Great Neck came from like a
middle-class Jewish family it was they
were not poor they were not you know he
was and apparently everybody I know who
worked with him including Heidi Perlman
who's in the book right there's a good
friend of mine um he was just a man she
was just a very sweet human being who
could get away with the Tony Clifton
stuff that he did because he was such a
good guy
in well there's my friend told me a
great story that he'd become pretty good
friends with him and one day Andy
Kaufman calls him up and said I got this
great new character Tony Clifton and
he's this insult guy he's a terrible
singer he's just nasty and everybody's
gonna hate him it's gonna be so funny
and then years later they
happened on each other and said he's
still doing the Tony Clifton character
and he said what are you talking about
I'm not Tony Clifton I said that's a
totally separate guy he said Andy you
told me when you made the character up
you called me and told me about him you
disguises
no no he's a different person I need to
know that it was him after he died I
can't think of the guy's name but the
guy that Paul Giamatti plays of the
muder went and did the character in
tribute to him for a while yeah hey I
met Orson once oh you did okay yeah I
met him at my friend Ted's house he
could barely get in the door it was
about two years before he died very
there he was holding court
shouldn't say I really met him because I
think ice I was so frightened you know
because I hold him at such high regard
that weird Tina that the one I was
telling you about who lived here voice
is assistant towards the end of his life
when he was doing his Mentalist act you
know he had a Osher he was yeah tea
magician all his life and he would she
would go out in the audience as a shill
and say you know what does this person
have in his pocket right he's got a
wallet in the comb Wow how did you think
about Orson Welles it's so tragic as to
have your greatest success when you're
24 years old and then you know you live
into your 70s and you never have that
again that's why we're glad we haven't
peaked yet um I had a very close friend
of my dad's as an actor named Elliot
Reid who you can look up he was and
everything he's in his 90s now but
Elliot was one of the mercury players he
lied to Orson Welles when he was 18 told
him he was 21
got into the mercury players on the
radio and then Orson had all these
movies that he didn't complete then he
would sleep with some countess and she
would give him the completion funds and
he would go and he call up ten and all
of these other guys that he worked with
and they go out to Palm Springs and
they'd shoot until he ran out of money
again so there's like as Peter
Bogdanovich was talking about they were
like they were like eight or nine income
uncompleted Orson Welles films that are
outing such a big deal about Schubert
one symphony yeah Wow interesting I mean
I learned all this late
you